you've discovered POI and you're super
excited to dive into it so what kind of
poi should you get and does the kind of
poi make a huge difference drexier from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and in this video I
want to share with you my picks for what
I think are the best sets of poi to
start out your flow Journey with before
we dive in I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys juggling calling pyro
Terra light toys spin balls and Ultra
POI for helping to make the videos on
this channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel Johnny Howard Lane machinski and
Becca becklinen thank you all so very
much for your support from my work and
my mission getting into POI is super
exciting in all likelihood you're trying
out something that's new and different
ever every new trick you nail and every
new discovery you make feels like
winning at the Olympics or finishing a
marathon but all that's dependent on
actually having a set of poi to work
with and this can be the cause of a lot
of anxiety for people especially at the
start of their flow Journey what kind of
poi should you buy should you make your
own do you buy fire POI to make sure
you're prepared for options ahead do you
get LED or daytime POI what about
contact POI there's a lot to untangle
here so to start let's cover how POI are
traditionally constructed and the
different types of poi that there are
out there hey if you're new here make
sure to like And subscribe so you don't
miss any of my new videos I post
multiple times a week on POI spinning
and flow Arts so keep your eyes peeled
every single set of poi consists of
three specific Parts ahead which is the
weighted end that normally spins farther
away from your body and is the thing
most people are looking at as you spend
the head can range from being a Kevlar
knot for soaking up Fuel and fire POI to
an assembly of electronics for Led POI a
spherical contact juggling ball or
weighted bag tucked inside of a set of
socks the tether a flexible leash that
offers up connection between the head
and the handle in older sets of fire POI
this is typically a metal chain but more
recently it's become fashionable to use
a flexible air mid-based rope called
tecnora in fire POI additional options
include an enormous range of different
ropes strings and even a segment of the
same sock that makes up the head and
finally a handle that is held by the
performer handles range from flexible
Loops of material in older sets of poi
to various versions of a ball shaped
form factor in most modern POI something
to bear in mind is that if you want to
be able to release your POI in throws or
contact rolls ball shaped handles are a
must given that there's only three
components to a single POI you'd be
shocked at the dizzying array of
different ways out there to construct or
use POI I would Whittle down that
taxonomy into three primary categories
of poi with several subcategories nested
within them first up are daytime or
practice POI these can be anything from
colorful sock POI to Garden variety
contact POI other options include POI
with tails to them or as they're
sometimes called Zuni POI and flagpoi
now it does have to be said here that
technically any set of poi can be
thought of as being practice POI given
that you can really practice with any
side of them but I'm specifically
setting aside POI for this category that
can fit into no other categories put
simply you can practice with any set of
poi but you frequently cannot light on
fire any set of poi that you may
practice with moving on the next major
category is what I'd call LED POI these
are POI that have battery powered LED
assemblies in the heads that are meant
to light up at night or in dark
locations so the POI heads can be seen
more clearly
head form factors may be rods teardrops
spheres or even assemblies inside of
socks within the LED POI world I would
also set aside three major categories
first are what I'd call single point LED
POI these are sets of poi in which the
patterns or colors produced are confined
to those that can be produced with only
a single point of light
this doesn't mean the POI themselves
have only one LED light inside of them
however generally there are several
oriented such that the light can be
clearly seen from any angle but they are
incapable of producing any patterns that
require more than one row of Lights to
construct next are what I'd call picture
POI they have multiple rows of LEDs
usually arranged in a rod like form
factor that flash on and off regularly
in such a fashion that they produce very
simple Graphics when viewed spun in a
dark environment finally there are what
I'd call programmable POI not only do
these sets of poi have multiple rows of
LEDs but you can also upload Custom
Graphics into them to produce whatever
pictures you'd like to in their Trails
these tend to be among the most
expensive POI out there and are the
go-to LED POI for most professional
performers and for our final category of
poi there are fire POI these consist of
sets of poi designed to be lit on fire
while they are spun the most common
version of this prop is constructed with
a small Kevlar knot mounted on the end
of a chain or an Airy mid leash like
technora or Kevlar variations within
this classification include snakes in
which the entire length of the POI
tether and head are all a part of the
same knot and that produce broad sheets
of fire trails and there's also cage POI
which are specialized fire POI with
metal cages on the end meant to hold
wood chips or steel wool to produce a
trail of Sparks or Embers as they're
burned A variation on this idea will
involve mounting sparklers to the end of
the set of fire POI please note these
are among the most dangerous sets of
fire POI because of a high level of risk
to the performer and the area around
them never use such a POI like this
unsupervised okay so that's a lot of
different options out there how do you
navigate all of them if you're just
starting out first up this may be a
controversial take but I would honestly
say to just take fire POI off the list
completely if you're starting from
scratch this is for several reasons
first there is literally no set of fire
POI out there that is forgiving they
they either carry metal hardware or are
packed in a dense enough fashion that
mistakes that result in collisions will
hurt second investing in a new hobby can
be a lot with the exception of
programmable POI fire POI on average are
more expensive per pair than
comparatively sized LED or daytime POI
start practicing with something that's
more forgiving and that looks cooler
during the daytime and or borrow fire
POI from somebody else who will
supervise your early Burns before
splurging for a set of fire POI and
finally it has to be said that despite
the many advances made in the past
decade at improving how comfortable fire
POI are to spin they still have a long
way to go to match non-fire options spin
with a set of poi that'll be fun and
comfortable to spend and that'll
encourage you to practice more at the
get-go cool so that narrows things down
to daytime and led POI most of your
first practice is likely to just be you
by yourself or with a couple friends so
you definitely don't need POI that are
made specifically for performances just
yet I see pros and cons to investing in
daytime versus LED POI up front daytime
POI are by and large cheaper but they're
also going to limit your options for
when you can practice if they don't
light up the stakes are also a lot
higher if you beat the heck out of a set
of LED POI and that you might damage the
battery or circuitry inside
but let's be real here there's also more
wow factor when you start out spinning
LEDs as opposed to more daytime options
I will say up front that I don't think
contact POI are a good first set of poi
for most people unless they know from
the get-go that's the style they want to
learn contact POI are heavy and hard and
unless you're committed to learning many
contact POI specific techniques I think
they become as much an impediment as a
benefit there's a lot to weigh here but
I do have some favorites so let me share
three picks that I hope will steer many
of you in the right direction first up
if you're coming down on team daytime
POI then my recommendation is a set of
sock POI from well sock POI they're soft
and forgiving and that's really
important at the start of your flow
Journey shipping can take a little while
because the shop is based in Russia but
seriously if you're looking for a good
balance between cost beginner friendly
and Visually stunning these really can't
be beat second if you are under the age
of about 17 I'd suggest just you start
with spin balls from fun and motion toys
they're super light and Incredibly
affordable they're built to take the
abuse that kids can Dole out to them
they're light enough that I think adults
will have a rough time making them work
and especially transitioning to other
sets of poi afterwards but for kids and
teenagers these would be my go-to
beginner recommendation but honestly my
top pick is really the most popular sets
of LED POI in the world pod POI there's
a reason they're so popular they have
really soft shells that make them very
forgiving for literally every type of
trick that you could try with them and
while the programming can be a little
challenging to navigate they do have a
wide variety of built-in modes that can
be fun to play with and they also have
an awesome warranty they're designed to
take abuse but the people at flow toys
will have you covered if they Buckle
under it at any point I think the
trade-off here is that they're
comfortable and soft enough to work for
daytime practice while giving you led
options so you can continue practice at
night there's no perfect option for
starting poi it but I think podpoi check
off more boxes than just about any other
set of poi that I can think of and if
you'd like to get a discount on a set of
them you can use my code drexfactor 2022
at checkout to get a discount on your
order yes I am sponsored by them but I'm
also sponsored by several other
companies as well these are the best
beginner option in my head regardless of
that
[Music]
what are your picks for the best sets of
beginner POI out there do you prefer to
make your own do you have a specific
shop that you like to support leave me a
comment and let me know this video would
not be possible if not for the wonderful
support of all of these amazing people
right here these are my flow patrons
over on patreon and they along with the
people listed down in the description
help to make this video and all the
videos on my channel possible thank you
one and all for your support do you like
my videos do you like my flow sessions
Vlogs reviews Combos and more I'm on a
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to The Wider world and help people
connect with their brains and their
bodies so help me do it head on over to
patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you are
watching on YouTube there you can get
access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and better yet help me along in
my mission do check that out please and
thank you if you are curious and want to
learn more about any of specific brands
or models that I've talked about here
I'll link to a playlist of poi equipment
reviews that I have done down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you are watching on YouTube the YouTube
algorithm also thinks that you'll like
this video up top based upon your
viewing habits so maybe give that a shot
too hey thank you so much for watching
make sure to get outside to flow today
and I will see you with a new video on
Wednesday